the new omicron variant of kovid has
overtaken the old delta variant of kovid
as the dominant strain in the united
states accounting for 73 percent of all
recent cases in the country according to
the cdc by the time christmas rolls
around public health officials are
predicting that 1.3 million americans
could be diagnosed with the virus
by the week that ends with christmas day
and according to the white house
coronavirus response director that will
be just the start
of a winter of severe illness and death
for the unvaccinated and everyone
and everything that they love
we are intent on not letting omicron
disrupt work in school for the
vaccinated
you've done the right thing and we will
get through this
for the unvaccinated
you're looking at a winter of severe
illness and death
for yourselves your families and the
hospitals you may soon overwhelm
that's right you evil people with your
selfish decision not to get vaccinated
you are going to take away hospital beds
from good people who made all the right
decisions like smokers who develop
emphysema and libertines who get
venereal disease and fatties who have
heart attacks you
you people
you're taking it away from those good
people who deserve medical treatment
because of their healthy lifestyles well
because of you america might shut down
again by new year's eve lest people
develop symptoms of uh
the common cold i'm michael knowles and
this is the michael knolls show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from katherine cook
who says they're not conspiracy theories
they're spoiler alerts
this is true dave rubin my friend dave
rubin got suspended for a little bit
from twitter some months ago because he
said the vaccines are not as effective
as they all told us they were going to
be and so they're going to start pushing
booster vaccines on all of us and
there's going to be a national mandate
and then he was suspended for
misinformation and then 100 of those
predictions
came true because they weren't he was
just observing what was going
on they're really considering shutting
down
new year's eve they're trying to cancel
christmas already you've got all the
public health authorities saying don't
go don't go to your families
take 15 tests take a few more jabs don't
maybe just stay home this year for
another 15 days for another what would
this would be the
second christmas that they'll shut us
down it's we're going right into number
three this is going to go on forever and
ever and ever and bill de blasio the
outgoing mayor of new york is saying he
might shut down new year's eve
in times square
so we've been in touch with times square
alliance
we're going to make a decision before
christmas
we're certainly looking at
the new challenge we're facing but again
this is an all vaccination event and it
is outdoors and those are two very very
important favorable factors
we're also considering there's other
ways we could approach it even with uh
the current uh the current rules that
could help to make it even stronger so
there's a discussion going on we will
have a final decision on what we can do
ahead of christmas for sure
uh and and we're working very very
closely with the folks who sponsor the
event to figure out what's the right way
to proceed
so we want to have new year's eve but
maybe maybe we won't now it's already an
all vaccinated event it's already
outside in the fresh air
well as fresh as air gets in new york
which is not very fresh
but we might have to cancel it anyway
so
what was the point
of the lockdowns and the masks and the
vaccines
what was the point the new year's event
in times square they've already said if
you're unvaccinated if you're one of the
filthy unwashed masses you're not
allowed to come even though it's outside
even though it's new york which is just
disgusting generally
you're not you're too disgusting for the
streets of new york apparently if you
don't take the vaccine
but they might have to cancel it anyway
this is one of the major events of the
year
we structure our year in events you
think oh christmas that's enough that
helps you put a mark around the year
it's a festival to celebrate easter that
would be another fourth of july that's a
secular holiday but we celebrate and new
year's eve and the most famous new
year's eve celebration in america is the
ball dropping in times square in new
york
and they might cancel that
we might put our lives on hold
indefinitely we've already done it for
two years we might just keep doing it
indefinitely
even for the vaccinated and the people
who mask and the most compliant people
so what was the point if you're going to
cancel this stuff anyway why did we do
any of this apparently none of it worked
so why couldn't we just live our lives
and see our families and have our
weddings and go to funerals and go to
holidays and go to work and keep living
why couldn't we do that if the end
result of all of these measures
is to still keep us all locked up in our
cages
what was the point
point i think the point was political
power for people i don't i don't want to
sound like a conspiracy theorist which
we've we've just learned that conspiracy
theories are spoiler alerts
but i there was no
there was no getting back to normal
and now some of the public health
officials are just telling us we're
never getting back to normal we're never
going to get on an airplane without a
mask again we're never going to do any
so what was the point
other than pure political power even new
yorkers don't like the way things are
going even in times square
there was a journalist who's doing a
cable news hit and even in liberal new
york as he's doing his hit on tv
some passersby expressed their views of
president brandon
as of now the ball drop
is expected to take place as scheduled
but that is under review
the mayor has said that he is going to
uh meet with times square officials and
look at the possibility of either
canceling or modifying that
celebration if the statistics do call
for it
they're expressing their views in very
blunt terms you see because they're new
yorkers
in the south where people use euphemisms
they'll say let's go brandon kind of
like bless bless your heart right
they'll use these nice polite euphemisms
but in new york they don't do that just
f joe biden go f yourself up your nose
with a rubber hose i don't you know and
so they're walking by and they're
expressing that view is it because
they're rock-ribbed republicans i don't
know maybe
or maybe it's just because joe biden is
extremely unpopular with good reason
he's always been a doofus he's never
accomplished anything
and now he's really really screwing up
our country because the buck is supposed
to stop with him
and he is
largely absent on the job and when he is
there he's making all of the wrong
decisions
most popular president ever got more
votes than anybody he got 80 bazillion
trillion votes in the 2020 election and
there were no fraudulent votes
whatsoever don't forget that
he's the he is
forget about the polls forget about what
you're seeing on tv forget about what
you're seeing at the sports stadia and
at the concerts he is
the single most popular person ever to
walk the earth
and if you question that they're going
to lock you up a little bit longer
but joe biden in fairness is not the
only person
getting heckled he's not even the only
president getting heckled
president trump is now on a speaking
tour with bill o'reilly and they're
doing this tour a few events around the
country and trump made his case
that conservatives should not oppose the
vaccines they maybe should oppose the
vaccine mandates but not the vaccines
trump said he's gotten the vaccine he's
gotten the booster and believe it or not
he ended up getting heckled by his own
crowd
this was going to ravage the country far
beyond what it is right now
take credit for it take credit for it's
a great what we've done is historic
don't let them take away don't take it
away from ourselves you're playing that
you're playing right into their hands
when you sort of like oh the vaccine if
you don't want to take it you shouldn't
be forced to take it no mandates but
take credit because we saved
tens of millions of lives take credit
don't let them take that away from you
okay so the president made do you agree
with that
right
both the president and i are vacs and uh
did you get the booster
yes i got it too okay so uh don't don't
don't don't don't don't know
that's always a very tiny group
it's a very tiny group over there
heckling me the rest deploy so trump is
in an impossible position
i know a lot of conservatives now are
just attacking trump because of his
coronavirus response
i'm a little lighter on him i don't know
a single politician on planet earth who
could have withstood the pressure
i don't know a single politician who's
being told that you will be blamed for
it that millions and millions of people
are gonna die and you will be blamed for
every single death on every tv news show
from now until the end of time i don't
know anyone who could have withstood
this
once in a lifetime event being told it's
historic proportions the fouchies and
the dr scarfs and everybody coming at
you i don't know who could have done it
but
as a result he
is the face of that coveted response
and you'll remember at the time you had
nancy pelosi and joe biden and kamala
harris and all the big leading democrats
as the vactines vaccine skeptics they
were saying i don't know if we're gonna
get this vaccine i don't know i don't
trust a vaccine made under trump so then
the roles flipped when joe biden came
into power
this is regardless of what you think
about the vaccine or whatever we'll get
into it a little bit later i think that
people
i think there is a better political
response to this
which a certain governor of florida is
giving out right now but regardless
this is trump's biggest political
weakness in 2024
this is the weakness
that he is
the the beginning of the coronavirus
response the coronavirus response up
ended our country i really don't think
it's totally his fault but that is going
to be it and if any republican
challengers want to come up against
trump in 2024 that's the angle they're
going to have to hit
now speaking of maintaining our
traditional american way of life
i would strongly recommend you check out
good ranchers christmas christmas time
is here time for joy and time for meat
that's not how the song goes but that's
how your christmas should go i have got
a wonderful
gift that you can give to your friends
and give to yourself that would be good
ranchers a box of 100
american meat that is steakhouse quality
goodranchers.com has a variety of boxes
to give or
give to the one you love whether that's
your friend or your family or yourself
they've got the ranchers classic for the
perfect combo of high quality beef and
tender chicken you can go with the
cowboy
that'll give you the ultimate steakhouse
experience with black angus rib eyes
wagyu burgers and more get 20 off and
free shipping on your order with my code
knowles at checkout plus your order
keeps local american farms and ranches
open and donates 10 meals to people who
would otherwise go hungry a lot of stuff
that says product of usa in the
supermarket is fake it's actually from
overseas or from latin america get the
good american stuff it's unbelievable
quality
get your good ranchers box or gift card
today head on over right now with code
knowles you'll get 20 bucks off and free
shipping go to goodrangers.com knowles
code knolls at checkout to take
advantage of this special christmas
offer
at least one potential 2024 presidential
candidate one of president trump's
potential rivals
is giving a slightly different answer on
vaccines and the virus and the lockdowns
than you're seeing from either trump or
biden that would be
governor ron desantis the other day dr
fauci said you know we could be that
fully vaccinated means three shots which
is two shots for the vaccination and
then one booster shot have you gotten
the booster so i i've done whatever i
did the the normal shot and you know
that at the end of the day is people's
individual decisions about what they
want to do but these boosters in terms
now florida we don't we ban vaccine
passports we we won't let them fire you
even private businesses over this
because we don't think that's
appropriate but one of the reasons why
we took those steps is because we knew
the definition of vaccination would be a
shifting target and i predicted this a
month and a half ago and people said
that that i was wrong and now we're
starting to see it come to fruition so
there's going to be people who've done
maybe two pfizer shots who are not doing
booster and they could be considered in
certain parts of the country to be
unvaccinated and then denied the ability
to participate in society like everybody
else it's gone way way too far and that
is a decision that people should make
for themselves but they should not have
their rights freedoms or liberties
restricted based on these boosters
this is a very sophisticated answer and
i'm not sure if governor desantis
listens to this show but he might
because what he is doing is exactly what
i suggested people do yesterday so i
hope he listens to the show or maybe
we're just a little simpatico on this
issue he gave a different answer
than trump or biden or the most
anti-vaccine people in the world
she said are you boosted
and he doesn't answer he kind of danced
right look and i and we've done and what
i've done what i've done is what i've
done and i had the normal shot and
basically but what i'm saying is this
and so he never answers the question
as
he shouldn't i think
the reason the vaccine answer from trump
makes him look weak is it makes him seem
like he's just totally going along with
the public health establishment yeah i
got the booster yeah i'll take however
many boosters you give me yep inject me
with the boosters that's fine i totally
believe dr fauci now look there might be
plenty of reasons for president trump to
get all the boosters but it doesn't
politically it doesn't look that good
then you have on the other side the
people who say i'm never going to get
that vaccine never stick me with that
needle no way know how it's going to
give me 5g and turn the frog's gay and
maybe that's true maybe it's not true i
don't know who knows i don't know i
don't study the frogs that closely but
that also is politically kind of a weak
answer that's going to seem a little
extreme to people a little out there
i don't even know that it's going to
play very well with republican voters
what desantis is answering is
i'm not i'm not giving you my medical
information i'm certainly not giving it
to you
moving forward
hey yeah it reminds me of one time i was
at a cigar bar
and someone asked me what kind of line
of work i was in and i told him and i
said so what kind of business are you in
he goes none of your f in business
i liked that line that's the answer
desantis gave
because if you really believe
that people should make their own
decisions and be allowed to make their
own decisions
then you shouldn't give the powers that
be
the knowledge of who has had exactly
what shots
you see that knowledge is power
when when your employer or the
government or a concert venue or a bar
asks you for all of your information
and they get it in some states they've
got these really highly sophisticated
digital scans and everything when they
ask you for all of that
whether you say you're vaccinated or not
they're getting more power
because then it's much easier to reward
and incentivize the people who've gotten
it and it's much easier to punish the
people who haven't gotten it joe biden's
national mandate only came out after
they believed that the majority of
americans had received at least one shot
politically he wouldn't have done it if
he didn't know that number
so i think it's much smarter here to
keep play this a little closer to the
vest make it a little unclear make the
ruling class a little uncertain about
just how much power they have just how
much sway they have just how effective
their policies are going to be
if you want people to make their own
decisions do not contribute
to to the
ruling class knowledge of who has and
who has not really smart stuff from
desantis now omicron that's the new
that's the new kovid
kovid kovid
how many have there been there was the
regular there was the og one
then there was the
the delta obviously i thought there were
a few before the delta now we're on the
omicron
spreading like wildfire
here's the headline
from the zoe kovitz study omicron and
cold-like symptoms rapidly taking over
london just a few days ago
cold like symptoms according to dr
angelique cotzie who's the chairman of
the south african medical association
don't forget we're now not allowed to
use national designations but omicron
was observed first really spreading in
south africa
she
was the first to diagnose a case of the
omicron variant she says the symptoms
are similar to a cold quote most of them
are seeing very very mild symptoms and
none of them so far have admitted
patients to surgeries we've been able to
treat these patients conservatively at
home
that's what she told reuters
if this is true
that it's spreading really really fast
and it's got these really mild symptoms
it means
that you are probably going to get
omicron
and it means you're probably going to be
just fine
that is basically good news
now what what the libs are going to say
and what the really not just the libs
but the fear mongers and the public
health they're going to say well
statistically if a certain number even
it's a very very small percentage of
people are going to die then the more
people who get infected the more people
die and so people are going to die and
this is a terrible i know i'm not
denying that
you're denying the virus i'm not denying
the virus
i'm accepting reality
and i'm recognizing that in an imperfect
world where we don't just always get our
way and we don't live in hermetically
sealed tubes
it is much better to have a virus that
even one that spreads very quickly if
the symptoms are generally extremely
mild that's good you're gonna get it
you're gonna get it you're gonna try to
lock up well not you you're very
intelligent people but the libs are
gonna try to lock up from christmas and
they're gonna stay home and if i just
lock myself up for five more years maybe
then i can avoid the omicron and i won't
get a cough and they're going to not go
to the new year's eve party and they're
not going to celebrate anything and
they're not going to go to weddings or
funerals or any of the things that mark
our lives and they're going to lock
themselves up and then maybe they'll
avoid the cough but probably they still
won't because you're going to get it
folks you're going to get it
and if
if the symptoms
are the symptoms of a common cold
or maybe somewhere between a common cold
and a flu
that's not so bad it's okay it's all
right
people used to get sick you remember
that you remember like three years ago
when people used to just get sick and it
was fine
and so and sometimes people would get
really sick and sometimes people would
even die and you know what you're going
to die too someday you are
but that's life that's life folks and
you can't hide from reality and you
can't
remake reality
but that's what they want to do beyond
beyond the omicron the left is trying to
remake reality even when it comes
to foreign policy when it comes to
everything you know i mean they're
trying to remake reality on the gas
prices which are going through the roof
which is why you got to check out get
upside around christmas time everybody
spends a lot of money more money than
they usually do well i'm going to
reverse that trend in one very important
area right now that's when you're
filling up at the tank and the way you
do it is with get upside my listeners
are making up to 25 cents for every
gallon of gas every time they fill up
just download the free get upside app in
the app store or google play right now
now if you use promo code knowles then
you're actually you're not going to get
25 cents back per gallon okay it's some
people say it's too good to be true well
no it's not it's actually not good
enough
to what you're actually getting if you
use code nulls you'll get up to 50 cents
cash back on your first fill up 50 cents
cash back right now with gas prices
going up to seven bucks a gallon in
california do not pay full price at the
pump anymore get cash back using
getupside download the app for free use
promo code knowles to get up to 50 cents
per gallon cashback on your first tank
super easy you can cash out right to
your bank account or paypal or an amazon
gift card if you prefer other brands too
just download the get upside app for
free promo code knowles get up to 50
cents per gallon cashback on your first
tank that is code knowles k w l e s
the left right now is trying to remake
reality
even with the
botched exit from afghanistan so joe
biden's national security adviser jake
sullivan
is now claiming at the council on
foreign relations
that the united
states safely
and effectively withdrew from
afghanistan
standing here in december that strategic
decision remains the right decision for
the first time in 20 years there are no
u.s troops in harm's way in afghanistan
this holiday season
we safely and effectively drew down
our diplomatic presence we lifted tens
of thousands of vulnerable afghans to
safety in a unique american example of
capacity commitment and sheer logistics
so whatever you think of america pulling
out of afghanistan
there's plenty of good arguments that we
should just run out of there and not
have anything to do with afghanistan
anymore there's some good arguments for
maybe holding bagram air base there's
some people are making the argument that
we should have just occupied the country
in
a significant way forever i'm not really
convinced by those but maybe you feel
that way
regardless of how you feel
about afghanistan generally
that dude is just lying he's just
rewriting history
it was not a safe withdrawal
13 service members were killed in a
terror attack
because
we gave up bagram air base before we
gave up before we got all of the
americans out we abandoned a ton of
americans there
to say nothing of our afghan allies
apparently every single person in the
country was an afghan ally
but
we left a lot of americans there too
we allowed these militants to empty the
jails and then some of the people
emptying the jails were then attacking
them whatever you think
the withdrawal was neither safe
nor effective and they're just going to
rewrite it and this is part of the
left's broader project okay
they they think that by
just changing all the words changing the
narrative changing the meaning of words
themselves they can remake realities
point in my book speechless controlling
words controlling minds which is a great
gift for christmas last minute shopping
also like reasons to vote for democrats
my other blank magnum opus which is a
great book for christmas but really when
you want to let the light in to your
home not just the light into your brain
but the light into your home you've got
to check out hunter douglas i did not
realize before i owned a house back when
i was still in little shoebox apartments
living in the cities before i moved to
the south i didn't realize
just how important your window
treatments are and the reason they're
important i should have realized is
because light is so important
when you're filming a podcast for
instance the thing that makes it look
good or look terrible is going to be the
way the light works when you're on a
beach what what makes it it's because of
the light the way the light plays on the
ocean the way the light this is true in
any home in any museum in any church and
it's true in your house too
they have incredible stuff over at
hunter douglas window shade designs
gorgeous fabrics control systems so
advanced they can be scheduled to
automatically adjust to their optimal
position throughout the day maybe it's
the way the shades diffuse the harsh
sunlight to cast that beautiful glow
across the room maybe it's the way they
give you privacy inside
maybe it's the superior insulation that
the shades provide you want that
goldilocks fit okay you want hunter
douglas's power view technology head on
over today to hunterdouglas.com
knowles for your free style get smarter
design guide with fresh text creative
ideas and smart solutions for dressing
your windows that's hunterductless.com
knowles canon wles for your free design
guide we've got some great news to tell
you about so i'm going to run through it
all right buckle up i'm going to as
quickly
and effectively as i can i am going to
tell you all the incredible wonderful
new news that we have at daily wire the
daily wire sent candace owens to
mar-a-lago to interview donald trump the
interview's airing tonight 9 p.m eastern
8 pm central only at dailywire.com if
you're not a member now is the time to
join if you want to show your support
for truth seekers like candace head on
over to yeswecandus.com
to pick up some great candice merch also
ben's got a new show it's called the
search his first guest is jordan
peterson they're going to be having
these kind of fly on the wall type
conversations over at a coffee shop head
on over to dailywire.com subscribe to
sign up today also daily wire is making
it easier to listen to all of our
content on the go with the launch of
listen this is the new section of daily
wire means you'll be able to listen to
all your favorite daily wire content on
the website and the dw app
we've made sure it's available to
everybody members and non-members so get
ready to listen head on over there right
now and you know
not only was the daily wire the first in
the nation to sue biden over the
unconstitutional vax mandates we're less
than 50 000 signatures away from hitting
our goal of one million signatures
on the do not comply petition
the sixth circus is really
it is a sixth circus the sixth circuit
court of appeals as it's sometimes
called is really jerking us around
reaching a million signatures will
provide a major boost to our legal
challenge head on over to dailywire.com
do not comply share it with your friends
and family we'll be right back with a
lot more
we talk about it a lot and it's getting
worse there is a gap between the
narrative that the left and the liberal
establishment and the ruling class is
peddling and the reality that we're all
seeing with our very eyes
you're seeing it especially with the
omicron variant right we're told that
the omicron variant's going to kill
everyone it's a winter of severe illness
and death you're going to die how did
you kids hide your wife we're also told
that it's extremely mild and it's like a
common cold
well
which is it these two things are
irreconcilable so here's another gap
having nothing to do with the virus
between the narrative and reality
very recently the san jose police
department's robbery unit concluded a
year-long multi-jurisdictional
investigation involving a prolific
robbery crew that targeted asians this
is according to breaking 9-1-1 asian
women in particular were frequently
targeted victims
many were injured during these robberies
so these detectives worked to identify
and arrest six
suspects who between october 2020 and
september 2021 committed over 21
incidents of robbery burglary and theft
directed at asian women
we now we have their photos we've got
the mug shots
and this white supremacy has got to stop
folks okay
got too much so much white supremacy
going on now if you are listening to the
show rather than watching the show you
may not notice that uh
the the fellows are not the whitest
people in the world okay they're not as
six young black men
and as a result you're probably not
going to hear about this story
when the attacks on asians began to tick
up a little bit last year we were told
this is because we're a country of david
dukes in the ku klux klan and nathan
bedford forest is riding around free all
over america pushing his white supremacy
and attacking helpless minorities
now the reality was never there it
wasn't this stuff was not being pushed
generally by white supremacists
but that's that's the narrative the
narrative is
white people bad black people good all
the bad things are attributable to white
people all the
good things are attributable to black
people
so when when black people do something
bad that is basically swept to the side
and when white people do something bad
that is amplified in the media sometimes
the white people don't even do anything
bad it's just contrived that they've
done something bad and so
some fictional narrative will be pushed
in the media i'm thinking of nick
sandman the the white kid with the maga
head on who was just standing there
doing nothing on the national mall while
some lunatic native american dude banged
a drum in his face and black
nationalists started screaming slurs at
him and he was the villain he was the
evil guy
kyle rittenhouse he just got off the
hook thankfully but it was a highly
contentious case because he was being
chased by other white guys who the libs
pretended were black guys
convicted
serial child rapists chasing this kid
the kid defends himself but because he's
a white guy he's a terrible murderer and
a racist
and a and a killer and a murderer
the takeaway from this of course is that
we can't trust
any of the establishments racial
narratives we can't trust any of them
obviously we can't trust the ones
that are that are being so
misrepresented here but it means we
can't trust any of them they don't have
any credibility
so even when they find the one in a
zillion ku klux klan the last klansman
in america they're going to find him
he's going to be living in the hills
somewhere and maybe he commits a crime
someday and they're going to blow it up
and make it a big news story
even that you can't really trust
because you know they don't have any
credibility none whatsoever
and they're not and they're almost
certainly not going to cover this big
robbery investigation now speaking of
immoral ways to make money there's a
really disturbing article
in the wall street journal just came out
long article titled nyu is top ranked
in loans that alumni and parents
struggle to repay
by any measures the elite manhattan
school nyu is the worst or among the
worst for leaving families and grad
students drowning in debt it feels like
i'm kind of trapped
so the story revolves around this young
woman cassandra jones who got a masters
in public health from nyu a couple of
years ago
and has not managed to get a job in the
field so she's got a six-figure student
loan balance
so she sold her eggs again direct quote
ms jones first started harvesting her
eggs before starting at nyu in 2017 to
help pay for moving into the city she
said she received a 12 500 annual
scholarship relied on 131 000 in federal
loans to cover the rest of her tuition
and expenses she's given her eggs five
times including to an nyu fertility
clinic earning 50 000 a year so this is
a political problem
this is an actual political problem a
social problem that we've all got to be
concerned about that people
whether because of ignorance or because
of naivete or because of just battle
decision making or taking out these hu
or or because of greed because they
think the loans are going to be forgiven
but whatever the cause they're taking
out all of these
loans
for
basically worthless degrees degrees that
even if they have some value which i'm
not convinced most of them do
even if they have some value they're not
going to put you on the track to be able
to pay back these
loans so that's a political problem we
need to figure out some way to stop that
there are policies we can use the
federal government could stop
underwriting these loans we could start
going after the universities we could
put caps on things there are plenty of
policies that we can use here okay
we could try to beef up the quality of
the education and so that kids at least
when they're spending their money or not
spending them on completely useless
degrees
also though we shouldn't let this woman
off the hook
okay
this is a personal problem too people
should value their children more than
money
and more than their own
job ambitions
it's not just that this woman one day
show gosh she found herself in six
figures of debt and she said oh my gosh
the only way i can pay the mortgage when
she doesn't have a mortgage the only way
i can pay the rent or buy some ramen
noodles to eat for dinner is by selling
my eggs that's not what happened the
first time she did it was before she
started nyu
because she wanted to get an apartment
in the city and she thought well if i
want a nice apartment i guess i gotta
sell my kids and if i can sell my future
kids then i can get a nicer apartment i
don't know maybe in the east village or
something maybe in greenwich village
near nyo that wouldn't that be nice
okay so she sells it and then she keeps
doing she's done it what five times now
yeah she's made 50 grand doing that
that's bad yes it's true
by selling your future children you can
make a lot of money especially if you're
a woman if you're a man you don't get
paid as much but if you're a woman
you're selling eggs it's very invasive
it's this whole surgery and they harvest
your eggs and you will get money but you
will lose something too
namely a relationship with your children
who are now going to be created in
laboratories
and will be raised by people that you
have no connection to that you don't
know you don't know how they're going to
raise them you don't know if they're
going to be raised in the right way in a
good healthy way
and you're not going to know your own
kids that's that's not that's not great
this is not the same thing as a woman
becoming pregnant and not feeling able
to raise the kids and then giving that
baby up for adoption
where there are an estimated 36 couples
for every one newborn baby put up for
adoption in the united states
this is intentionally
creating a child or participating in the
creation of a child
to never know that child to
intentionally deprive that child of her
natural mother
and to do so for a little bit of luker
for a bag of coins so she can get some
stupid worthless degree at some
overpriced rich kids school so that she
can have a fun time going to bars in new
york this is bad stuff okay and
sorry that i can't manage to work up the
waterworks to feel really sorry for her
okay yes we need public solutions to
this yes we need to fix it at a
political level but also
where are her parents i mean who
where did she get the idea that this is
the right thing to do or moral or just
in any way it's not so stop doing it
especially for what to get a public
health degree from nyu good grief
how did oh gosh
bad trade lady bad trade to trade your
kids for a public health degree from nyu
and a few
good manhattans at a at the bar in
greenwich village
not smart stuff
speaking of public health rip uh senator
rather debbie stabenow democrat senator
debbie stabenow
is is really upset because her senate
colleagues
cory booker
and lyowatha elizabeth warren have come
down with the coronavirus and they're
all vaccinated they've got the jabs
they've got multiple g they've got three
jabs and counting who knows how many
more they're going to get but they still
gotta break they got breakthrough cases
i don't know how many breakthrough cases
we need before we can stop calling them
breakthrough cases
i think most of the people i know who
have gotten the coronavirus recently
have been vaccinated but it's all
breakthroughs
millions and millions of breakthroughs
okay
breaking i think there's not a whole lot
to break through if they're all getting
through
but they've gotten the virus and debbie
stabenow is blaming
her republican colleagues because
even though
many if not most of them have been
vaccinated
because they won't continue to wear the
stupid masks in the capitol
we've heard now that senators warren and
booker both have had breakthrough cases
have you heard of any more cases and uh
what concerns do you have about
the way the
protections against
uh covet in the senate as you've all
been working together so closely
well we are working together closely
people on my side of the aisle are
uniformly wearing masks unfortunately
people on the republican side majority
are not which is also frustrating but um
i
obviously send them my best um thank
goodness they have both been vaccinated
and received the booster which hopefully
means that they will not have serious uh
symptoms as a result of this that's
really what needs to happen people need
to get vaccinated they need to
protect themselves we know that this new
variant is extremely contagious and we
also know it is not that serious if you
have been vaccinated
so i would encourage everyone to do that
as a christmas present
as a holiday present for themselves and
the family
so
so which is it
is this a big deal and it's really
serious or is it not a big deal and it
shouldn't even be on the news which is
it because stabenow and msnbc and
the left broadly want it to be both
to begin she's lying when she says that
democrats are wearing masks in the
capital and republicans are not that's
not true i've got it i've got an in at
the capitol i've got an in in the senate
okay i'm not going to name my source
let's call him
ked trues
yes senator
kedrews that's a pseudonym
but he has mentioned that in
private gatherings between republicans
and democrats
let's say when they're on the bus to bob
dole's funeral let's say when they're in
a room in the capitol where there is no
there are no tv cameras
the democrats almost to a person do not
wear the masks they only then put the
masks on when they go outside to see the
tv cameras so what what she's saying
here that all the democrats are wearing
their masks that's just a lie
and even if so why would why would you
need everyone to wear the masks if
you're
triple vaccinated i thought the whole
point of the vaccine is it's supposed to
protect you so does the vaccine not
protect you okay
well then stop making people get the
vaccines oh no it does okay you're
saying it does protect you but you still
need to
you still need to wear the mask but if a
triple vexed person can get seriously
ill then the vaccines aren't worth
anything if they can't get seriously ill
then shut up about it who cares you're
gonna get it it's a cold get over it
okay sorry to be so blunt i'm just
reading the the
zoe covid study
all right from just reading with the
public health officials in south africa
i'm just reading what the cdc are saying
which is that in its effect as
to the best scientific knowledge that
we've got the omicron feels like
a cold
so then why are we listening to these
women on tv fearmonger
why are we canceling christmas why are
we canceling new year's eve
because
because these people don't have any
credibility
that's that's why they're tying
themselves in nuts why are we paying
attention that because they have a lot
of political power i guess and probably
there's some probably the reality is
that there's some combination here
maybe the breakthrough cases
are
a little breaking through a little bit
more than they're pretending maybe the
vaccines are not quite as effective as
they all told us it were maybe it's just
not maybe the narrative is not quite
what everyone was telling us it is
so what
is the senate going to do about this
well they don't need to worry all that
much they don't need to worry about
sending cory booker home or elizabeth
warren home because the senate is
adjourning until january 3rd and the
senate is adjourning
without any major legislative
achievement for joe biden
because the build back better plan this
is joe biden's signature
plan this was going to be all the big
spending all the big priorities
is dead for now because moderate
democrat joe manchin is saying he's not
going to vote for it
and the progressives the far
progressives are really upset about this
the head of the congressional
progressive caucus is demanding that joe
biden pass the build back better budget
plan the 2 trillion plan
without ever even going through congress
congressman pramila jayapal who is the
progressive caucus chairman of the house
of representatives says quote
it is incumbent on president biden to
keep his promise to us and to the
american people by using the ultimate
tool in his toolbox of executive action
in every arena immediately
at this point we should not wait for the
legislative path for the president to
take action i just think there are too
many americans hurting there's too much
at stake we have trusted for too long
that senator joe manchin was engaging in
good faith
but he won't go along with them so now
it's bad faith i am not willing to hang
my hopes and futures of millions of
americans across the country on whether
or not he will do what he said he would
do yesterday which is often different
from today or tomorrow so
in terms of the
political philosophy point she's making
it's completely incoherent
she's saying we've got to work for the
american people and so we got to we got
to get through this budget plan by
hooker by crook
but the american people have already
said they don't want the budget plan
one they've said this through lots of
public opinion polls but two they've
said it through their elected
representatives the people are electing
members of congress and members of the
senate and then their elected
representatives have to decide speaking
on behalf of the american people whether
or not they're going to pass this plan
and the elected representatives decided
no they're not going to 51 of those
elected representatives in the united
states senate said no we don't want this
plan so if you're just talking about the
will of the people the to the best
evidence we've got of it the american
people don't want this terrible spending
plan
so jayapal is wrong on that point
as a tactical matter though whether it
is advantageous for democrats to ram
this thing through with executive orders
without ever talking to legislators and
whether that's even possible
i think jayapal's probably right
i think she's probably right i don't i
don't think that
the senate really matters all that much
i don't think the house really matters
all that much i don't think our
government is run in the way that
schoolhouse rock told us it is with a
bill up on capitol hill and the three
branches of government the checks and
balances and the separation of power i
don't think that's an accurate
representation of our actual
government
i touched on this a little bit yesterday
joe biden got
zero accomplished
in terms of legislation this year
practically zero accomplished he got a
lot accomplished through executive
orders
just on day one he
opened the u.s border gave de facto
amnesty to millions of illegal aliens
started pushing a ton of covid measures
rejoined the paris climate agreement
that was day one of his presidency just
through executive order
he then issued a massive
vaccine mandate unheard of in american
history
to affecting well over 100 million
americans he just did that with the
stroke of a pen he didn't go through
congress for that
he surrendered afghanistan which is it
was an american imperial holding he just
surrendered that he didn't need the
senate for that they didn't need to
ratify a treaty because they didn't have
a real war going on
it was all just kind of being done by
the president
so yeah i'm not sure that he needs the
senate
maybe a little bit here and there but
probably he can just do whatever he
wants
that's how he's been governing anyway i
think it's i think it's a right-wing
coping mechanism to say that joe biden
got nothing accomplished in his first
year he got a ton accomplished this is
probably the most radical
year of a presidency in my life
just the border alone by october they
had two million illegal aliens come
across the southern border that is
insane i mean that is a crazy crazy
number
so
but don't tell me that he hasn't done
anything he just it's even worse because
he hasn't done it through the ordinary
means
the polls have not discouraged joe biden
the
the representation of the people's will
through their representatives has not
discouraged joe biden actually the
deputy press secretary
jean-pierre
who is who is somehow much worse at her
job than jensaki
jean-pierre was asked if joe biden is
planning to run again he's going to be
about
600 years old in 2024 and his approval
numbers are in the gutter and his vice
president's approval numbers are somehow
much much worse they're between 27 and
28 lower than dick cheney's after they
had waged the iraq war and after he shot
a man in the face and they're still
lower than dick cheney's in 2007. so
what's going to happen joe are you out
are you going to run again are you going
to give it to mayor pete or somebody who
are you going to run with kamala harris
and the white house says
100
everything's staying the way it is i'm
hoping you can clear something up here
when it comes to the question of 2024 uh
the vice president did an interview with
the wall street journal and she was
asked if she assumed that biden would
run again and she didn't say yes she
just said that the two of them hadn't
talked about it of course you all and
the president himself has said that he
does plan to seek re-election so
what's the disconnect here well i i mean
i can't speak to a conversation that the
vice president and the president has i
could only say what and reiterate what
jen has said and what the president has
said himself that he is planning to run
for re-election in 2024 i i don't have
any more that but just
so it's not a definitive answer but as
of right now they're saying and you know
you're you're getting a little bit
closer if he's really going to move
aside
then
they're going to have to start working
on this you'd think a little bit leaking
out but right now joe biden is saying no
i'm going to run he's got basically the
best approval rating in his entire
cabinet
the only one who's on par with him is
pete butterjudge and p buddha judge is a
joke
the mayor of a small town in indiana who
is then transportation secretary who
took two months off the job in the
middle of a crisis to to
have maternity leave or something
to recover from the child he didn't give
birth to
so
biden very well might be the best shot
right now although i will say before
before we go i will leave you with this
to talk about
death and severe illness and destruction
john durham who's the special counsel
investigating the origins of the russia
hoax investigation john durham
is now
reportedly investigating the hillary
clinton campaign
he's investigating
lawyers for the clinton campaign
into their role in the origin of the
steele dossier and the russian and that
therefore was used to spy on donald
trump and start the russia investigation
it's extremely complicated and it's
still
going on and there would seem to be a
link there
john durham is investigating the
political arm of the clintons and so my
main takeaway from this is one he's
going to be sorely missed we're going to
miss him
i'm sure he's going to come down with
depression at some point you know and
he's going to be found having shot
himself several times in the head
and that's too bad and it's really sad
especially around christmas time for his
family the other thing i will say
looking ahead to severe illness and
death and
you know looking ahead to what we can
guess and fear at into the future
i would not necessarily count hillary
clinton out in 2024 i'm michael nolis
the michael knowles show on that spooky
note i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
john bickley here daley wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our new
show morning wire
on today's episode senator manchin kills
biden's build back better act
closing arguments in the galain maxwell
trial begin and google imposes strict
vaccine mandates
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire